hey guys
if you live in a country like me where
you need to drive everywhere then you
need a few things in your car that just
makes life so much easier so much better
especially in those unforeseen unknown
situations winston churchill said
he who fails to plan is planning to fail
now i'm not going to waste your time i'm
going to get right into the list of
things that you need in your car number
one
[Music]
sunglasses
if you drive a lot then you know it's
terrible to find yourself in a situation
where you're driving the sun is right in
front of you is just rising or it's just
going down you can't see a thing so just
keep sunglasses in your car and it'll
help it's also going to be great because
whenever you go to a certain venue when
you need sunglasses then you'll have it
a car phone charger or just the cables
for those usb ports in your car believe
me this is the best thing that you can
keep in your car always especially if
you use google maps on your phone
[Music]
pen
believe me for some reason you always
just need a pen in your car trust me on
this and you'll thank me
[Music]
jump cables look this is just a
no-brainer keep it in your car at all
times because it saved lives and the
time of many men across the world
[Music]
all the equipment for a flat tire do you
know what to do if you get a flat tire
well you won't be able to do anything if
you don't have the right equipment so
you gotta have a spare tire with a jack
a wheel lock and a crush wrench when
you're on a road trip and you're just
enjoying your time you don't want to get
stuck with a flat tire and not being
able to change it so make sure that you
are prepared for a flat tire
a flashlight believe me when you're
driving at night and your car breaks
down or you get a flat tire you want to
see what you're doing and you don't need
a big flashlight just a small one that's
powerful a lot of few options for you in
the video description i'll do that for
everything on this list
[Music]
a blanket
for some reason long trips with a
blanket is just awesome and you can also
just fold it up and use it as a pillow
or if you're really going on long trips
just add a pillow as well
[Music]
a snow brush or a ice scraper believe me
if you live somewhere that's really cold
you want to have it in your car all the
time because you don't want to get stuck
somewhere just because you don't have it
with you
a traditional road map personally i
think it's cool you know some of those
things in the old good days the new
generation they don't know how to use it
anymore but some of it really comes in
handy for example if you're driving
somewhere your phone dies you can't use
google maps then you still have the old
roadmap that you can use
emergency cash in your car you're gonna
need it sometime sooner or later it
happens believe me it happened to me a
few times you're driving somewhere for
some reason your car doesn't work or you
can't find an atm and you need real hard
cash then you still have it in your car
mints or gum
in your car
all the time man the number of times
that this helped me when i had to go
from one occasion to another and i just
felt man you can feel when you have bad
breath
it saved my life a few times i use
fisherman's friend because well they're
just awesome
wet wipes or tissues i actually learned
this from my wife but you don't want to
eat in a car or change a flat tire or do
something else and then your hands are
dirty and you don't have anything
to clean it with so tissues or wet wipes
man it's awesome because you don't want
to touch your yourself your face or your
steering wheel with dirty hands
a bottle of water
there's nothing worse than being stuck
in traffic and you're thirsty or on a
long road trip and the gas station is
far away you don't have water yeah what
if your car breaks down in the middle of
nowhere you you don't have any water but
just remember don't keep a normal
plastic bottle just in your car because
it's not good with the sun there the
whole day my advice is whenever you go
somewhere take a bottle of water with
you don't just leave it there in the car
and get a bottle that is bpa free
bisphenol a
a pocket knife or a multi-tool believe
me it's going to come in handy because
well you can't predict everything that's
gonna happen and what you will need
right when you're away from home but a
pocket knife and a multi-tool will
definitely help with most of the
problems that you may encounter oh hey
just before i continue with the next
step if you like this video if you like
my channel please subscribe and then
also click that notification bell so you
won't miss any of our future videos i
would really love the support from you
guys all right the next tip is a first
aid kit and i don't really need to tell
you why do i
[Music]
food i don't really like to keep food in
my car all the time except if i go on
long trips not things that will go bad
quickly
but a protein bar for example is perfect
a phone clan if you use your phone for
google maps just to know where you're
going where you're heading then why
don't you just get a phone clamp because
it's so much better so much more
convenient and it's safer as well
now this is an important tip deodorant
and antiperspirant believe me you don't
want to get somewhere to important event
or even work and then you remember you
forgot to put on any deodorant because
believe me you don't want to be that guy
that smells terrible and everybody is
trying to avoid now just a bonus tip
it's always good to keep a bag in your
car a one-nighter bag meaning just a bag
with some of your basics in it so for
example if you visit your friend that
lives far away and he's late and you
decide man i don't want to drive back
home then you have that bag in your car
with your toothbrush with one set of
clothes etc or imagine you go somewhere
you quickly stop you want to get coffee
and the barista spills coffee all over
you then you still have that set of
clothes in your bag now there are
certain things that every guy must have
cheap things check out this video here
where i mentioned 20 cheap things that
every guy should have and before you go
always remember life is short so don't
waste yours cheers guys